pour ça vous donnerez du pipa lee mais
point trop long je vais vous monter
parce que vous connaissez pas avec du
lait des conseillers en thérapie donner
aux élèves sophie bennabi suit une
formation à urt veda avec joyce willaume
le don thérapeute et formatrice
spécialisée dans cette médecine indienne
c'est une élève qui est assidu qui est
très enthousiaste qui a déjà participé à
la journée de la rna en tant que
comme masseuse qui est très dynamique
dans le groupe
une journée avec des patients les élèves
apprennent à gérer une consultation un
questionnaire à suivre pour permettre de
mieux coller de son patient avant de
passer à l'auscultation là on va prendre
votre pouls pour voir les dochards par
les énergies qui sont en déséquilibre
dans votre organisme
ça ça correspond au dos chavatte a donc
au dos chat qui correspond aux éléments
de l'air de l'air et de l'espace le
majeur c'est des aimants de l'eau et du
feu et l'annulaire c'est les éléments de
la terre et de l'eau et donc en fait ça
ça nous permet de déceler les dochards
donc y en a 3 bat à pita et capa est de
savoir donc d'où provient le
déséquilibre par rapport aux éléments
que j'en étais moi j'ai dit écrit-il
vata une progression pitt a un poids
assez chaud assez long quand on a un
excès de pita c'est quand on a beaucoup
de feu donc ça va se traduire par des
inflammations par beaucoup de colère par
beaucoup de
de volonté de contrôler en fait sa vie
et il son travail à 27 ans sophie
bennabi suit sa deuxième année elle a
commencé sa formation de médecine
indienne en octobre 2016
il ya un an la décide de changer de vie
professionnelle elle quitte son poste
d'ingénieur en informatique et se
reconvertit dans l'activité ayurvédique
l'ayurveda c'est un rêve et un petit peu
par hasard en lisant des livres en
tombant sur des articles sur internet
bon ben voilà coup de foudre donc c'est
une médecine indienne qui veut dire en
fait la science de la vie alliant meda
ça veut dire sciences de la vie et c'est
une médecine en fait qui allie
l'alimentation les soins corporels et la
spiritualité avec ces outils de thérapie
a reçoit chez elle une à deux personnes
par semaine pour des soins ayurvédiques
massage consultations médicales conseil
bien-être différentes prestations
thérapeutique avec des tarifs entre 40
et 55 euros les séances mélangé à ces
révisions je revois les cours que j'ai
en présentiel sur paris dans mon école
d'ailleurs veinards et puis je lis des
livres en fête des livres
les livres les livres sacrés de
l'ayurveda les traités de l'ayurveda
qu'on doit apprendre en fait ce qu'on
appelle les textes classiques donc je
dirais vie je les apprends j'essaie de
classées par thématiques en décembre
dernier se fit bennabi partie pendant un
mois en inde elle a pu bénéficier de
conseils de professionnels dans un
hôpital ayurvédique c'était plutôt des
patients en fait que j'ai rencontré et
bats la structure de l'hôpital fin les
personnes qui s'occupaient de la
structure de l'hôpital que j'ai
rencontré aussi donc vraiment des
personnes qui étaient baignées dans
l'alluré d'art se fit bennabi souhaite
faire de nouveaux voyages en inde pour
pouvoir affiner sa formation en laye
hoveyda